whether you're a product manager a CMO
or CEO chances are you're facing many of
the same problems every day how do you
find new users how do you keep them and
how do you get them to invest a little
bit more I'm assuming that people in
this room know a fair amount about this
question and I'm assuming a fair number
you also know that 50% of users find new
apps and games through word of mouth
from their friends and from the family
and research tells us that 50% users are
more likely to engage with an app over a
long period of time if they can actually
use it with their friends and family yet
more often than not we dedicate our
resources our time and our money to the
other 50% users looking at indicators
and incentives that are targeting
individual users taking individual
actions and why do we do this the answer
is pretty simple it's easier to measure
and it's easier to understand we know
exactly how long it takes somebody to
fulfill a specific task within the net
we know exactly how many people click
through the ad in the game but these
tend to be lagging indicators markers of
decisions that we've already made and so
clearly there's a gap there we should be
thinking about the forward-looking
indicators the decisions that help us
get to that other 50% of users that are
harder than measuring the ones that are
motivated by word-of-mouth define new
items ones that have community and
relationships to drive long-term
engagement and so my name is Jared and
with me as Sam we're from context
partners those of you that don't know us
we're based in Portland Oregon where we
focus heavily on insights and engagement
and have decades of experience
strengthening relationships growing
communities and building loyalty
for brands and causes for this project
we partner with three incredible
organizations Gameloft Gameloft
butterscotch shenanigans and free
weddings three organizations that
understand the value of relationships
and the power of community we started by
interviewing their developers and their
community managers trying to understand
what really is working for them and what
isn't from their perspective and then we
spoke to their users to understand
what's actually working and what's not
and do this we used a wide variety of
qualitative research methodology but
focus primarily on surveys and
interviews to understand the role that
action games play in their users lives
and this gave us a window into how
people were talking about apps how
they're recommending apps in person and
through text conversations as well as
realizing how they are using apps with
each other in person and across long
distances and very quickly we realized
that not all word-of-mouth is created
equal not every relationship leads to
engagement and through all of these
conversations we read the same refrain
people want more human connection
especially with people who love the
things that they love especially people
who care about the things that they care
about when people have these kinds of
connections that's when you see word of
mouth driving to adoption is this better
today we're going to look today we're
going to look at how and why users have
these kinds of connected experiences
we're going to look at how developers
create opportunities for meaningful
connection and we're gonna encourage you
to change the way that you think about
the way that you approach your work over
the next 20 minutes or so we're gonna
introduce you to three principles that
we've seen to be most effective in
driving towards connected experiences
investigating personal affinities as
clues to underlying values challenging
users to reach beyond themselves to
connect with others and finally creating
unexpected connections that make
experiences feel magical and as you hear
these stories I want you to continue to
think about how to bring this back to
your own work into your day-to-day way
now I'm going to ask Sam to share a few
of the stories that emerged over the
course of the research conducted for
this project
Thank You Jared I'm so excited to speak
with you today about the things that we
learned from getting to know these
developers users and players and as you
listen to them I want you to be thinking
about the mindsets behind money of the
stories that you're going to hear not
just the specific tactics that these
developers used because over and over we
heard that you need to design for your
specific communities in their specific
moments we have a lot to get through
today let's get started on this first
mindset I want you to think about
something that we all know we all know
that we should be giving our users what
they want if what they want is a feeling
of progression we're gonna deliver that
feeling of progression if what they want
are high quality graphics we're gonna
deliver high quality graphics and if
what they want is astronomy we're gonna
give them the stars but the opportunity
that we saw was for developers to look
beyond just thinking about what their
users liked and using those affinities
as breadcrumb trails that you can follow
to the deeper values that your users
will love to build communities around we
heard from a user of the star walk to
app this is an augmented reality app for
staring at the sky and learning about
constellations and clearly this was a
user who loved the Stars but what we
heard from him was that he was having
these connected experiences with the app
he was using it with his father with his
uncle they were tracking celestial
objects across long distances with each
other
and now what was driving that connection
wasn't just an affinity for the Stars
it was the shared value that they had
the sense of wonder that you get when
you look up at the sky and we saw the
same thing when we spoke to users of
Gameloft's dragon mania legends this is
Debbie and her daughter Hannah and
Debbie told us that she plays this game
because her daughter recommended it to
her
Debbie plays this game because she loves
dragons and so we kept talking to Debbie
and we said where does this love of
dragons come from Debbie and she said
well my whole family loves mythological
creatures I raised my kids in the arts I
would take them to Renaissance Fairs
when they were kids I try to take them
to the limits of their imagination so
when Hannah recommended this to Debbie
they weren't connecting over that
affinity for dragons
they were connecting over that deeper
value of imagination and a family and we
saw this over and over again in the
broader spectrum of Android users that
we looked at
the people who want to connect over
calendar apps want to connect over the
value of respect when it comes to other
people's time the people who choose
bodyweight apps over gym equipment want
to connect with people over the value of
discipline and making no excuses when it
comes to their health and the couple
who's tracking their finances together
is connecting over the value of
commitment and saying I'm committed to
our future but how did we know that
these users were expressing deeper
values and they weren't just connecting
over these affinities well for this part
of our research we had sent dozens of
Android users out into the real world to
capture the conversations they were
having around apps and games they
brought us into their dinner parties
into their lunch breaks at work into
their text message conversations and
what we saw is something I think a lot
of you know people love to talk about
apps and games they love to share apps
and games with their friends but so many
of those conversations don't lead to
more app adoption don't lead to ongoing
engagement and we wanted to figure out
why what we learned is that not all
word-of-mouth is created equal we heard
from users of Finance apps like mint and
chase mobile and these users would tell
us I love recommending these apps to my
friends I showed them these beautiful
pie charts I tell them about the amazing
typography I try to tell them how easy
it is to use these apps and yet my
friends don't use them even when I go so
far as to install the app on their phone
for them they still don't start using
the app but when we talk to users who
were successful who did get their
friends to start using apps we heard
something very different we heard from a
mint user who said I struggle with my
finances so I asked a friend of mine who
looked like she had it all together and
I said how do you do it how do you stay
on top of your money my friend told me
it's hard for me too I use mint so I can
see how I'm spending my money and try to
do a little bit better next month it's
hard for me to these aren't to people
who are connecting over an affinity for
pie charts or typography these are
people connecting over there deeper
values of control and struggle when it
comes to their finances so today is
about mindsets and what we want you to
think about here is how to look beyond
adjust your users affinities take what
they like as the beginning of the
journey of learning about the deeper
values that people love to build
communities around this is work that's a
lot more fun to do than you might think
we
a lot of context partners and if you
think of it as ethnographic research or
you think of it as qualitative research
studies it can sound really daunting but
what we're really talking about is
giving your users space to tell you
their stories what your app really means
to them and this will make your
decision-making easier because you'll
know which parts of your app really
connect to those deeper values that are
driving your word-of-mouth engagement
now today what I want you all to do is
think about a project you're working on
right now a decision you're facing
something you're gonna have a meeting
about tomorrow and I want you to plug
that decision into a series of questions
here's our first one and asked will this
feature that I'm working on this new app
that I'm developing this marketing
campaign that I'm putting together
connect with what's truly meaningful to
our users because answering this
question is how you're going to appeal
to that 50% of users who finds their
apps and games through word of mouth
this is how you're going to appeal to
that 50% of users who will be more
engaged with apps that they can use with
their friends and family because it's
those values that they're going to be
connecting over and if you're having
trouble answering this question it's a
good time to take a step back and learn
which of your users affinities map to
those deeper values so this is the first
step as we're building these bridges of
connected experience first we need to
get to know our users and we recommend
digging into their personal affinities
to find their underlying values next we
need to get our users outside of
themselves and one of the most effective
ways we saw developers doing this is by
using challenges to motivate their users
to reach out to others to illustrate
this I want you to think about a moment
in your life when there's something you
desperately wanted that was just out of
your reach
something that you just couldn't quite
get to alone what did you do did you
give up or did you reach out for help I
want you to think about a moment in your
life when you truly accomplish something
great something that meant a lot to you
and it was really hard what did you want
to do right after I know for me I want
to tell other people about it and not
just anybody I want to tell the people
who understand who know what I've been
through who know what it's like and
that's what we heard from so many of
these Android users in the stories they
would tell us about their favorite apps
and games we heard these stories of
challenge of struggle of overcoming
those were the best stories the ones
that made us want to try new apps
apps like freeletics in a lot of ways
freeletics is built around this concept
of challenge their company that makes
several health apps and they're best
known for one that coaches users through
bodyweight exercises over the past five
years they've built not just a big user
base 20 million users but an active user
community people who workout together in
public at freeletics training spots
around the world and what was so
striking when we spoke to these
freeletics users was the pride in their
voices the passion they felt about
freeletics so much of that passion came
from how hard the workouts are that's
what we heard from users like Eliot I'll
tell you right now Eliot is a user you
want if you care about community because
Eliot is the kind of person who shows up
a training spots and he welcomes new
users warmly it's important to him that
people have a great first time at these
training spots he's the kind of user who
doesn't just buy the premium
subscription for himself he buys premium
subscriptions as gifts for his friends
and family and when I asked Eliot this
incredible user what did you like about
freeletics when you first started using
it this is what he told me he really
didn't his exact words were mmm liked
isn't the word I would use he said it
was too intense but at that moment in
his life that intensity that challenge
was exactly what he was looking for
freeletics delivered it and now this is
what he says the people I work out with
are the people I hang out with he
welcomes new users warmly he buys
premium subscriptions for other people
why because he wants other people who
know what it's like who've experienced
the challenge and we heard this from
every freeletics user we spoke to they
all want to be around other people who
know what it means to train multiple
people said I want to be around people
who remember the pain how often do we
think about removing pain from hurt
users and these users are telling you I
want to be around other people who
remember the pain because it's that pain
that drives them to reach out to others
and I know some of you are probably
thinking well yeah this is a fitness app
people want to be challenged in fitness
apps but my users want everything to be
easy and you're mostly right when it
comes to the transactional parts of your
app when it comes to your login screen
the navigation of your UI
make these things as easy as possible
but when it comes to the core experience
of your app the reason your users are
there that's the time to challenge them
that's the time not to say well that's
fine for freeletics but to ask what is
the freeletics of finance look like what
would drive the most passionate
pinterest or memorize users to get
outside and make their things with
others and obviously there's tons of
room to talk about this in games so we
talked to the indie developers at
butterscotch shenanigans these are the
makers of the hit game crash lands and
the forthcoming level head obviously a
studio who knows how to connect with the
values of their users and they told us
about a constant debate when they're
making games something that I'm sure a
lot of you have faced how much
information should we give our users
should we tell them everything - they
need to know make things super easy but
risk some users leaving if this is too
boring too obvious or do we hide some
things give our users that wonderful
feeling of challenge and discovery but
we risk losing some users if we make it
too difficult well for crash-lands they
lean towards guiding the player through
in-game instructions like this one their
players were never unclear on exactly
what the next step in their game should
be they always knew exactly what to do
but these guys are experimenters so they
made one exception this is the Mega Gong
the most powerful weapon in the game and
I can see on your faces this is a fish
sword you want I can tell this was a
fish sword their users wanted to so for
this one they made things more difficult
they didn't give their users all the
information they hid things they made
real challenges users were gonna have to
complete tasks that had about a 1 in a
thousand chance of success and what do
you think happened did the users who
love this game leave throw up their
hands and quicks it was too difficult
just the opposite this challenge is what
drove users to their forums inside the
butterscotch shenanigans forums you saw
users posting screenshots coming
together trying to solve this together
strategizing with each other this was a
single-player game and this weapon this
challenge became what brought users
together so what would your users work
for what's the awesome fish sword
they're waiting for you to build No
today is about mindsets again and this
one
can take a little bit of a mindset shift
for some of us because challenges can be
counterintuitive we all want to make
things that are easy to use we want to
make those slippery sales funnels that
our users can slide right down and when
it comes to the transactional parts of
our apps we absolutely should but again
when it comes to the challenge when it
comes to the core experience of your app
this is the time to think about what
will my users reach out to others for
what will they really work for think
about the best stories you hear and the
best stories you tell the things you
keep telling around your office I'm
betting I'm betting that these aren't
the stories of everything coming easily
of everything working out of you always
knowing exactly what to do the best
stories are full of challenge and your
users want it too so let's think again
about this decision we're facing
tomorrow this project we're working on
and now let's ask this question will
this inspire our users to stretch beyond
their limits because answering this
question is how we're gonna get again to
that 50% of users who'll be more engaged
with apps that they can use with their
friends and family this is how you'll
get them to reach out this is how you're
going to connect with the 2/3 of users
who say they'll be more engaged with
apps that they feel an emotional
connection to you're going to create
that emotional connection by genuinely
challenging them so as we're continuing
to build these bridges of connected
experiences we've talked about how to
get to know our users better we've
talked to now about how to use
challenges to motivate them to reach
outside of themselves now let's talk
about how to bring them together because
we said at the beginning that your users
have this desire for connection they
want to be around other people who love
the things that they love who care about
the things they care about but so often
what we're pushing our users towards our
individual actions we're tracking the
things that individual users do to meet
metrics that individual users can meet
it's like we're a bookstore and our only
KPI is did we sell one book to one
person did one person buy one book and
they got out here great success that's
fine but it's awfully limiting because
the opportunity that bookstores have is
to create the kind of space for
unexpected connections that truly make
experience is magical that feeling that
your customers your users can have when
they can say I came here for this but I
found that
sociologists have known about this
effect for decades they tell us that one
of the keys to developing friendships to
developing relationships is to have
repeated unplanned interactions repeated
unplanned interactions it's the way that
you just bump into people in the
bookstore in the coffee shop what we
found in our research is that this is
not limited to the physical world your
apps and games can do it too
I spoke to a user of the game dice duel
I don't know if they're in the house
tonight but this is dice duel this is a
game for virtually playing dice and she
told me about how I recommended this
after my dad because I played dice games
with him when I was a kid thought he
would like it she was right he loved it
what happened next she was not expecting
she said this is a guy who won't check
his text messages who won't use whatsapp
but inside of dice tool we are having
the kinds of repeated unplanned
interactions that are strengthening our
relationship I can always find him there
and when I tell that story people often
tell me well that's just luck some of
our users are always going to find
connection around our apps and games we
don't need to design for it
we can't even design for it and I'm
telling you that it's not luck
bookstores and coffee shops are designed
experiences when you spend time in them
you can see how they're designed to send
traffic in ways to put people together
many of you probably know the story of
the Pixar building that is designed to
bring people from different departments
together in unexpected and unplanned
ways because they knew that it was those
moments where the real magical ideas
were going to come from your apps and
games can do the same thing let's take a
look at how Gameloft does it again
inside of Dragon mania legends this is
Nina and Nina told me that like so many
dragon mania legends players she came
for the Dragons but what she found was
something very different she said she'd
been playing for a little while she was
getting bored and she decided to join an
in-game clan for anyone who doesn't know
clans and leagues inside of games are
like teams where 20 people work together
share resources strategize compete
against other teams and the team that
Nina joined was very intense this is a
group of people that vets new users to
make sure they can stay committed to the
game they want people from all over the
worlds that someone can be grinding 24
hours inside the game and they formed a
real community they maintained a
separate Facebook
messenger group where they share
pictures of each other's puppies and
keeping up with each other's lives and
get each other excited about what's
coming next in the game this was not
what Nina came for Nina came for the
Dragons
she found a real community of people who
love what she loves who cares what she
cares about and it wasn't luck it wasn't
coincidence Gameloft designed this space
for her am i tell you about two
decisions they made one inside of this
team there is an in-game chat window so
people can communicate with each other
that one might seem obvious but I've
seen a lot of apps and games now that
try to appeal to the idea of teams and
they tell a bunch of users you're all on
a team now but there's no way for them
to interact with each other where they
put users into multiplayer modes where
they play a bunch of random people one
time and leave wondering if they were
even playing against real people that
chat window is how Nina is able to have
those repeated unplanned connections
with those people grinding inside the
game 24 hours a day game loft also makes
it really easy for people to not just
join these teams but to leave them
because we're talking about sub
communities of players very specific
cultures there's a good chance you're
not gonna join the one you want right
away they make it easy to leave and try
another one game loft is designing this
experience and players like Nina are
filling it with that magical feeling of
connection so again today is about
mindsets and what we're asking you to do
with this one is to think beyond
individual users taking individual
actions that you can easily measure with
individual metrics and think about how
you can drive towards deeper connections
real meaningful storytelling the kind of
thing that's going to drive long-term
engagement with your apps because let's
look at the users we've talked about
Nina was getting bored the community is
who she plays for now if we go back to
Elliot and freeletics Elliot told me he
downloaded freeletics so he could work
out alone now that community is who he
plays for now Nina and Elliot have both
been daily active users for years these
developers are solving problems that all
of you face how do we keep long-term
interest for our users how do we keep
subscriptions going how do we create
surprise and delight and novelty for
them well think about where you find
those things in your own life you find
it in the bookstore and in the coffee
shop when you keep running into your
friends maybe you find it on an airplane
when you strike up a great conversation
with someone who just happens to have
the same backpack as you maybe it's at a
conference
where you come to learn more about your
industry but you leave thinking about
all the new friends you've made each one
of these things can feel like luck can
feel like coincidence but they're all
designed experiences and you can design
those experiences too by taking a look
at that decision that you're facing
right now and plugging it into this
question which is will this move us
towards a culture where relationships
thrive are we creating the spaces for
the kinds of unexpected connections that
make experience is truly magical because
this again is how we're gonna get to
that 50% of users who find their apps
and games through word of mouth the 50%
of users will be more engaged with apps
that they can use with their friends and
family answering this question will do
that for us so at context partners we
had such a great time getting to know
these developers and users and players
we had so many ideas and stories that
we've been kicking around that have
really inspired and reinvigorated us in
our own work and I hope these three
mindsets have done the same thing for
you we've talked about getting to know
your users better by using personal
affinities to dig into their underlying
values how to use challenges to motivate
them to reach out to others and how
unexpected connections can truly make
experience is magical
I'll bring Jared back up now we've been
talking a lot about bridges and
connecting people and connecting people
and it's through these moments that you
really start to see things happen once
you realize that you're not the only one
that loves this app or feels this way
about the game these are the experiences
that drive community experiences like
the one that we're all having now where
you can connect with the people around
you over the idea of connecting with
people as a task worth taking on and so
what should you do after you leave the
room today
bring back mindsets not tactics think
about how you can bring these into your
work every day we've introduced the
questions about how to create those
spaces to inspire people to reach beyond
themselves and asking if this is the the
kind of work that will move toward those
places where relationships can really
thrive and as you do that I want to
leave you with one question where will I
build bridges today thank you